[Music]
yesterday you completed your tasks for
us and then you left right away you
usually hang around what was I was told
there was a medical problem yeah we're
good we don't have to go there I had a
situation and let me talk about my
kiddos I don't know no I well I'm
intrigued I know better place to talk
about something on the air oh you left
my show you are in my employ you're
supposed to stick around throw I always
do sir
yes but you left last night and I'm
worried about Shane most of medical
emergency what do you Gladys Kravitz who
cares what happened to me there's a
reference the kids are loving now Google
that you're gonna laugh your ass off
it's a nice reference so what happened
what's the medical problem it's not a
big deal all right here's the okay
here's the deal
and by the way anything I say is gonna
look like you know preschool compared to
what Russell Brand talks about but I
have a situation I got a medal cool I
got a gentleman situation going on I've
got I gotta go here's the deal I've got
what they call chronic epididymitis you
familiar with that no never heard of it
uh it's you your epidermis gets infected
and it feels like somebody is stabbing a
knife in your testicle oh my god that
sounds horrible yeah I walk around with
that about 23 hours a day and I had a
really bad bout of it yesterday and and
it hit me as I was here and it just
literally buckled me over and it's awful
yeah and it sounds terrible yeah you're
welcome comedy not happening oops it
does why is he talking about he was
right not to talk about this yeah so I
when I was here yesterday I had a
horrible bout of it so I called my
doctor you know my doctor dr. Bini boba
and
I called my doctor and they said well
you know we're not gonna be a you coming
first thing in the morning at us and I
look I was literally crying I was in so
much pain and I was like yeah okay I'll
come into the upcoming in the morning
I'll do whatever I can and so that I'm
here and I'm literally sweating and I'm
in so much pain to the doctor they
called me back and they said you know
what your doctor said he's gonna wait
for you he's gonna stick around and wait
for you can you rush over and listen I
don't want to leave here you do a
terrific job and but I did I raced out
of here and I and I got to Beverly Hills
in record time and I get there and sure
enough they stayed there for me the
doctor waited for me there's no other
patients there they're literally waiting
for me the entire staff is there they
welcoming in they rushed me in they're
all there waiting with the coats and
purse in hand waiting for mr. Pardo to
be seen that's great a whole medical
office is staying just for me they're
all there for me so I go into the room
and they the doctor starts giving me the
tests he starts at poking and prodding
and doing what needs to be done little
behind the scenes action and I don't
know if that's a medical term no no no
just creepy yeah and then I happy I give
a urine sample and then they as I think
we're done they suggest that I have to
give a um I think of a sperm sample
right and I said well why do I come back
for that
and they went no no you need to do it
now I'm like pardon
yeah and they're like yeah you gotta you
know yeah yeah you know what yes could
you go in that room and give us a sperm
sample and make it snappy
yeah the entire so here's the deal
everyone wants to go they all want to go
Conan and they say go in there and
masturbate so I'm glittery I walk two
feet away from where everybody is closed
the door that's made out of I don't know
plywood and I hear them talking and all
the time I what are you gonna do tonight
I don't know if let's get the hell out
or I can't wait to get out of here as
I'm trying to finish masturbating
they're all there literally if let's
pretend there's a wall here yeah you're
talking about leaving I'm gonna get out
of here I gotta go first of all you're
doing it wrong I just found out your
problem you you recommend I use my head
is that what you say there's like this
yes wrong yeah whatever whatever you're
doing must be great look here's the deal
so yes I discovered I this a lot of
people suggest well that might be a
turn-on not for this kid it was awful it
took me I don't know ballpark 45 minutes
they waited 45 minutes they must hate
yes of course they do and then I walk
out and they all know what just happened
right
like I walk out well thanks everybody
and they view grabbing stuff and leaving
awful I feel bad for you oh you're
better now though no you didn't even get
you didn't even get admiring looks from
the female staff members for your
stamina 45 minutes yeah totally you
spent 40 of it just sitting there
[Music]